hey 42 here mother-in-law is an anagram
of Hitler woman welcome to Rick it is
forbidden for aircraft to fly over the
Taj Mahal a cat uses its whiskers to
determine if a space is too small to
squeeze through there's a bookstore in
Australia where books are wrapped in
paper with short descriptions on them so
no one can judge a book by its cover the
u.s. spends more money per person on
health care than any other country yet
its life expectancy is below average
mailing an entire building has been
illegal in the US since 1916 when a man
mailed a 40,000 ton brick house across
Utah to avoid high fright rates more
than a thousand different languages are
spoken on the continent of Africa
cats have only a hundred vocal sounds
dogs only have ten two-thirds of the
world's caviar is eaten aboard the Queen
Elizabeth two cruise ship early draft
names for Walt Disney Seven Dwarfs
included flabby dirty shifty lazy dirty
Baldy and bigger ego a shark is the only
fish that can blink with both eyes
certain frogs can be frozen solid
then Ford and continue living beauty
pageants for children are banned in
France they are punishable with up to
two years in prison and a 30 thousand
euro fine Walt Disney was so poor in his
20s that he had to eat dog food the
smallest trees in the world are the
dwarf willows of Greenland's they are 2
inches tall
Albanian has 27 words for different
kinds of moss
dashes and 34 eyebrows thanks for the
view subscribe for more 42